fue en el vídeo pasado en el cual
resolvimos esta integral y para resolver
esta integral lo primero que hicimos fue
este cambio de variable x es igual a
tres veces el seno de teta y haciendo
este cambio de variable llegamos a esta
integral que tenemos aquí la cual salía
con una sustitución usando un poquito de
trigonometría dijimos que era igual al
coseno de teta y haciendo este cambio de
variable llegamos a una integral muy
sencilla
llegamos a esta integral de aquí la cual
tenía como solución esto que obtuvimos
hasta acá abajo esta es la solución de
la integral con respecto a b pero la
integral original estaba en términos de
x por lo tanto lo que vamos a hacer en
este vídeo es pasar todo a términos de x
y para esto tengo que hacer la
sustitución hacia atrás y el primer
cambio de variable que yo hice era igual
al coste no de teta por lo tanto podemos
poner aquí igual al coste no beteta y
después escribir todo en términos de x
sin embargo x está en términos del seno
de teta ahora lo que voy a querer hacer
es escribir lo que tiene que ver con el
cociente de teta en términos del seno de
teta de hecho aquí está nuestro cambio
de variable
decía que x es lo mismo que es donde lo
pongo lo voy a poner yo creo que aquí
acaba aquí x es igual a tres veces el
seno del ángulo teta el cambio de
variable de color magenta me decía que x
es igual a tres veces el seno de teta ya
que voy a despejar un poquito al seno de
teta y me va a quedar que x entre 3 es
lo mismo que el seno de teta y bueno
dense cuenta que está escrito en
términos del coste no de teta mientras
que nosotros tenemos a x en términos del
seno de teta estaría muy padre estaría
genial que nosotros podríamos escribir
el coche no como algo que tenga que ver
con el seno de teta por lo tanto vamos a
intentar hacerlo es igual al coste 9
teta y si nosotros usamos la identidad
de econométrica básica me queda que el
concepto de teta es lo mismo que la raíz
de uno menos el seno cuadrado de teta
uno menos el seno cuadrado de teta esto
utilizando la identidad trigonométricas
básica la pitagórica y esto es lo mismo
que la raíz de uno menos el seno
cuadrado de teta
pero el seno es x entre tres por lo
tanto me quedaría uno menos x entre tres
al cuadrado
raíz esto es lo que vale y ya está lo
único que tendremos que hacer es
reemplazar en esta expresión por esta
expresión que tenemos aquí que está en
términos de x bueno esta es la primera
forma de resolver esta sustitución hacia
atrás sin embargo en el resto del vídeo
lo que voy a intentar hacer es hacer un
método alternativo para hacer este
cambio de variable la idea es escribir
esto de una manera mucho más sencilla y
que quede todo primero en términos de x
y después de una manera mucho más
elegante y bueno para hacer esto voy a
dibujar un triángulo rectángulo que
cumpla que tenga un ángulo llamado theta
si este ángulo éste está entonces el 100
9 tetas el cateto opuesto entre la
hipotenusa y esto me quedaría así esto
es el seno de teta y bueno quién va a
ser el coste de 9 teta bueno el coste de
tam está definido por el cateto
adyacente entre la hipotenusa pero este
cateto adyacente lo voy a obtener con el
teorema de pitágoras el cateto adyacente
es igual a la raíz de la hipotenusa
elevada al cuadrado es decir 3 al
cuadrado que es 9 menos el otro cateto
elevado al cuadrado es decir menos x
cuadrada
tenemos aquí el valor del cateto
adyacente por lo tanto quien va a ser el
coste no detecta el coste no detecta es
el cateto decente que es la raíz de 9 -
x cuadrada esto entre la hipotenusa que
es 3 y esto lo podemos escribir de la
siguiente manera esto es lo mismo que un
tercio que multiplica a la raíz de 9 - x
cuadrada y si yo quisiera meter este un
tercio adentro de la raíz entonces tengo
que elevarlo al cuadrado para poderlo
meter adentro de la raíz por lo tanto
esta expresión va a ser igual a la raíz
de un noveno que multiplica a 9 - x
cuadrada este 1 b no es lo mismo que un
tercio adentro de mi raíz lo eleve al
cuadrado y todo esto lo estoy haciendo
para que me quede lo siguiente vamos a
seguir haciendo todas estas que brillan
en la parte de abajo y por lo tanto me
va a quedar un noveno por 9 que es lo
mismo que 1 - x cuadrada entre 9 que es
lo mismo que x cuadrada por un noveno y
esto es justo lo que tenemos aquí arriba
por lo tanto hemos llegado a la misma
expresión x entre 3 elevado al cuadrado
es lo mismo que x cuadrada entre 9 y
hemos hecho justo lo mismo y llegamos al
mismo resultado x
tanto lo que voy a hacer a continuación
es sustituir av y ahora si está en
términos de x bueno pero antes voy a
escribir esto de la siguiente manera
esta raíz es lo mismo que 1 - x cuadrado
entre 9 elevado a la potencia un medio
recuerden que un medio y la raíz es lo
mismo por lo tanto ahora sí voy a
sustituir a un y en lugar de poner aún
voy a poner toda esta expresión de x que
tengo aquí entonces me queda 243 que
multiplica a elevado a la quinta
potencia que es lo mismo que 1 - x
cuadrado entre 9 todo esto elevado a la
un medio por 5 es decir 5 medios
si yo elevó esta expresión que tengo
aquí a la quinta me quedan cinco medios
y todo esto dividido entre 5 y después
tengo 1 - x cuadra de entre 9 que está
elevado a la 3 medios esta expresión que
está en un medio elevado al cubo es lo
mismo que tres medios entre 3 y a todo
esto le voy a aumentar una constante de
integración y por fin lo tenemos aquí ya
tenemos la solución en términos de x y
para esto lo que tuve que hacer fue
primero una sustitución trigonométricas
y después
normal hicimos una sustitución de bueno
métrica una sustitución normal y después
hicimos las sustituciones hacia atrás
para escribir todo en términos de x y
así obtener el resultado final